[Música]
[Aplausos]
cresci numa família de empreendedores
numa cidade da serra gaúcha de 60 mil
habitantes chamada vacaria lá morei por
16 anos
meus pais dedicaram as suas vidas ao
ensino fundamental médio e universitário
minha mãe depois de se aposentar com o
professor do estado fez pular virou
advogado se tornou mestre em direito
penal 52 anos e hoje leciona em cursos
de graduação
meu pai não só foi pedagoga integral
como também ajudou com sua universidade
e foi diretor dela por mais de dez anos
têm orgulho máximo das suas carreiras
vocação legado dessa forma desde que me
conheço por gente a educação faz parte
da minha vida me desenvolvi um ambiente
familiar de profundas discussões em
relação à formação do ser humano
mas será que a educação atual em massa
criado há 200 anos para formar os
operários das fábricas tanto precisavam
adequadas e hoje será que as habilidades
ensinadas até aqui serão as habilidades
exigidas daqui pra frente
sessenta e cinco por cento das crianças
que estão hoje na 1ª série vão acabar
trabalhando em atividades completamente
nova que ainda nem foram criadas o que
nós enquanto indivíduos sociedades e
nações o que nós precisamos fazer hoje
para atender os anseios dessas crianças
que daqui a 20 anos vou exercer com
muita força o seu poder de compra no
mercado mas não temos idéia onde vão
trabalhar
será que é fazendo o que fizemos até
aqui
ou será que estimulando novas
habilidades pouco estimuladas
até então o que mais diferencia o ser
humano das demais espécies é a nossa
capacidade de pensar
perdemos em força e tamanho para outros
animais mas o que fez a gente permanecer
nesse planeta foi a nossa inteligência
a tecnologia criada até aqui
principalmente depois da revolução
industrial ela potencializou em muito a
força humana
lembro das máquinas das fábricas tudo
isso otimizou os nossos músculos
porém esse período que nós vivemos agora
ele é tão mais profundo do que a
revolução industrial porque pela
primeira vez na história a tecnologia
está potencializando justamente aquilo
que mais
diferencia dos outros a tecnologia hoje
potencializa a nossa capacidade de
pensar raciocinar e tomar decisões
a tecnologia está fazendo pelo nosso
cérebro o mesmo que as máquinas fizeram
os nossos braços na revolução industrial
as máquinas que vão passar a fazer parte
da nossa vida daqui para frente são bem
diferente dessas que nos trouxeram até
aqui porque agora as máquinas pensam e
agem por conta própria através do
aumento da acessibilidade diminuição dos
custos convergência tecnológica várias
inovações estão desembarcando juntas
inteligência artificial carros autônomos
robótica troms realidade virtual
biotecnologia alimentos produzidos em
laboratório internet das coisas moedas
virtuais impressoras tv tudo isso está
fazendo com que o emprego dos sonhos de
muitos jovens não exista aqui dez anos
o que fazer então para se manter
competitivo nos dias de hoje
compartilho com vocês cinco habilidades
e competências que no meu entendimento
são hoje fundamentais vitais para
qualquer pessoa se manter na vanguarda
daquilo que executou o primeiro a causar
impacto
causar impacto significa melhorar a vida
das pessoas e para isso é preciso ter
propósito propósito qual é a razão da
sua existência porque você está aqui o
que faz você acordar todo santo dia e
botar a cabeça no travesseiro qual é o
seu propósito
quando você tem um propósito claro o seu
cliente não compra de produtos e um
funcionário trabalha pra você tem
investidor não investe na sua empresa
quando você tem um propósito claro essas
pessoas fazem algo muito mais profundo
porque elas passam a acreditar no que
você credita sonhar com que você só é a
marca que você ama não pode não se
apaixonar por você mas ao fim dem a sua
causa
para trabalhar propósito para causar
impacto três pontos são importantes
primeiro necessariamente é preciso
melhorar a qualidade de vida das pessoas
em algum aspecto a pessoa o chacal sem
ter saído melhor do que no shopping a
pessoa no término do relacionamento com
você tem que ter saído melhor do que no
início a melhorar a qualidade de vida
das pessoas
b corrigir o errado
foi se o tempo que você poderia oferecer
algo mais ou menos para as pessoas e
ainda assim se manter competitivo porque
hoje não tá bom você eu tenho outras dez
soluções talvez melhores e mais baratas
que a sua então identificou uma falha e
não tem nenhum problema de falhar a
falha faz parte do processo e
identificou uma falha não deixe para
corrigir amanhã nem depois corrigir
agora e ser prolonga o certo encontram
algo que as pessoas gostam recebem
feedback positivos satisfação é ótima
para longas certo faz um certo ter vida
longa
ninguém hoje constrói nada sozinho nessa
vida ninguém é uma ilha você precisa de
muita gente pra fazer que os seus sonhos
esse objetivo número um então é se
cercar de talentos gente boa
só que o talento ele sabe que é
talentoso o talento não investe o tempo
dele em qualquer lugar porque porque
talento trabalho propósito por impacto
em acta a sociedade onde vive
ele quer deixar um legado uma marca na
sociedade onde está e faz parte
por isso a gente boa que embarcar num
foguete meu amigo é pra outra
ou você apresenta o foguete parece
camarada ou esse talento da investida
genialidade dele longe de você
segundo olhar a próxima curva em meados
de 1800 existe uma indústria
extremamente bem sucedido nos estados
unidos a indústria do gelo
naquela época existe um dos coletadores
de gelo
as pessoas esperavam chegar se mudaram
para as regiões mais frias dos estados
unidos buscavam lagos congelados com uma
picareta cortava o docs de gelo colocava
uma charrete de cavalo transportava para
cidades que é inovação naquela época
inovação eram mais cavalos cavalos mais
fortes mas charretes lamas mais afiadas
quanto mais a queda e alana mais rápido
conta o degelo mais o produto
porém 30 40 anos se passaram e um
cidadão inventa forma de congelar
artificialmente a água na estação
central e cria fábrica de jogo
poxa agora não precisa mais esperar o
inverno chegar
eu não preciso mais me mudar para uma
cidade congelada porque eu posso
fabricar o gelo 24 horas por dia sete
dias por semana 365 dias por ano e como
as fábricas ficam perto das cidades
rapidinho eu transformar o consumidor
mas 30 40 anos depois um outro cidadão
otimiza o processo e cria o refrigerador
eu que já não mais precisava dos
coletadores de gelo agora também não
preciso mais das fábricas de gelo porque
qualquer cidadão do mundo agora no
conforto do seu lar consegue fabricar
seu próprio jogo porque o conto essa
história porque nenhum comentador de
gelo se transformou na fábrica de gelo e
nem uma fábrica de gelo se transformou
em uma fábrica de refrigeradores porque
a grande maioria das pessoas
infelizmente até hoje se define baseado
naquilo que elas fazem e não no
benefício que elas entregam se define
como uma pessoa que corta dotes de gelo
lá congelada você sempre um coletor do
gelo cima define como alguém que congela
água artificialmente uma estação central
você sempre uma fábrica de gelo silva
definiu qual alguém que fabricam tem
sido mais chamado refrigerador
você sempre uma fábrica de
refrigeradores mas qual é o seu
benefício o cliente quer o gelo para
gerar só água invadindo coletador da
fábrica do roteador pouco importa você
pode ser um perito cortador de gelo
melhor de todos quando já existe a
fábrica de gelo
por isso a importância de olhar para uma
curva porque ao dominar o processo de
canibalização do que você faz você obtém
uma versão melhorada de si mesmo
3º questionar
infelizmente evoluímos no sistema
educacional que privilegia o aluno que
responde na hora
224 nota 10 porém nesse mundo onde cada
vez mais as inovações estão questionando
as verdades dos padrões das normas
moedas virtuais questionando mercado
financeiro aplicativos de
compartilhamento de corrida questionando
as leis municipais no mundo hoje as
verdades estão sendo questionados se
você não questiona as verdades atrás é
muito grande
ao questionar três aspectos são
importantes de serem mencionados a
quando você questiona você entra em modo
no fashion black tem diz
ou seja você começa a questionar as
verdades começa a questionar normas que
este homem busca soluções quando você
encontra você se move rápido na frente
dos demais
um fastback franz b à normalidade nunca
mudou nem nunca vai mudar nada o
pensamento médio é uma doença que corrói
indivíduos sociedades nações
quanto mais você questiona mais distante
você tá do pensamento mediano e ser a
repetição não criar memórias o que cria
memória são novas experiências
você escuta uma música boa pela primeira
vez mais leve e essa música demais pela
quinta vez nota 10 para a décima vez
pela vigésima atriz já não aguenta mais
ecológica
talvez você lembra o que você fez um ano
atrás nas suas férias mas não lembro que
você fez ontem porque quando você entra
em modo repetitivo você não cria mais
remota no automático o que faz você
criar memórias são novas experiências
quando você questiona você cria novas
experiências e criar memórias quarto
fazer com as pessoas e não simplesmente
para elas
nesse mundo onde tudo muda a cada vez
mais rápido o risco de você trabalhar
meses no projeto para só depois desses
meses você descobrir que ninguém quer
consumir que você criou esse é o grande
risco para minimizar isso traz as
pessoas para dentro do processo
produtivo faz com elas não se faz mais
algo para as pessoas se faz com as
pessoas e isso é bem diferente 2016 não
sem um livro todo o processo do livro
foi feito com o leitor
o texto está pesado estava leve a
linguagem faz assim forçado capas acorda
ótimo desempenho incrível de título é
esse como leitor e não para o leitor
e quando você faz
as pessoas quando você traz velas para
fazer junto com você ela se sentem parte
do projeto tanto quanto você e quando se
sentem parte do projeto tanto quanto
você elas passam a acreditar naquilo que
você credita a sonhar com aquilo que
você sonha limpa proposta máquina você
ama e com elas se sentem tão parte do
projeto quando você elas passam a
compartilhar exatamente a visão que você
compartilha de forma espontânea
centenas de pessoas compartilharam
milhares de fotos do livro o livro já
passou da quinta edição e foi durante
várias semanas o livro de negócios mais
vendido do brasil no mundo onde este
cidadão no meio do nada com o celular
das mãos conectado à internet e acesso a
mais informações que bill clinton
acessava 20 anos atrás quando foi
presidente estados unidos não considerar
hoje esse camarada no processo de
produção do seu produto é um completo
desperdício quinto ser diverso ao
convivermos conversarmos almoçarmos com
as mesmas pessoas possivelmente
chegaremos sempre as mesmas soluções
muito difícil algo em comum sair dali
porque a criatividade ela surge quando
confrontamos a nossa forma de pensar com
pessoas que pensam diferente da gente
quando os esporros ao inusitado à
diversidade de pensamento é fundamental
hoje em dia para criar algo singular e
único vale do silício onde moro é uma
das regiões mais inovadoras do planeta
ea diversidade é um dos temperos do seu
sucesso 50% das pessoas que moram no
vale nasceram fora dos estados unidos
ou seja é muita gente diferentes
nacionalidades diferentes religiões
raças cores orientações sexuais
muita gente diferente tinha tudo para
dar errado mas dá certo porque essa
região abraça diversidade usa seu favor
enquanto boa parte do mundo enxerga essa
bandeira e olha apenas uma causa o vale
olha para o bandeira enxerga o respeito
a toda forma de diferença
e pra promover a diversidade de
pensamento há mais de três anos eu tenho
uma meta de conhecer uma pessoa por dia
uma pessoa diferente podia conversar com
essa pessoa entender os problemas
compartilhar receber informações na
semana tem que ter conhecido sete
pessoas
é impressionante
quando nós crescemos enquanto seres
humanos quando confrontamos a nossa
maneira de pensar com pessoas que pensam
muito diferente nós
dessa forma causar impacto olhar a
próxima curva questionar ao invés de ter
resposta pronta fazer com as pessoas e
não simplesmente para as pessoas e seus
versos são habilidades que no meu
entendimento são vitais para qualquer
pessoa hoje fazer algo com sucesso
a tecnologia tá democratizando
praticamente todos os setores da
economia e educação é um deles
em breve a educação que o filho de um
casal bilionário vai receber vai ser a
mesma educação que o filho do casal mais
pobre do mundo
nesse mundo onde o conhecimento cada vez
mais é uma commodity perecível onde a
internet que essas crianças não vêm da
ásia acesso é tão poderosa quanto à sua
não é mais um rótulo uma credencial que
define o ser humano mas é o seu
comportamento porque quando eu olho para
essa foto mais uma vez o meu orgulho e
imensamente de ter me apaixonado pela
mesma vocação dos meus pais pela vocação
de ensinar mas não de ensinar as
habilidades do passado que nos trouxeram
até aqui
mas para ensinar as habilidades e
comportamentos virtudes e hábitos que
vão levar a sociedade a dar o passo à
frente porque educar não é fazer alguém
aprender a educar é ensinar e se alguém
há como continuar aprendendo e com a
humildade que ainda tem muito que
aprender na vida é com muito orgulho que
eu recebi da minha querida vacaria o
título de cidadão emérito do município e
do congresso nacional do meu país
a medalha juscelino kubitchek de
personalidade empreendedorismo
brasileiro
isso me dá mais forças para continuar
aprendendo e para encerrar quero deixar
vocês com a mensagem de um dos
principais poetas que esse brasil já
teve carlos drumond de andrade que
reflete muito bem esse período longe
aprender desaprender e aprender de novo
é fundamental para construir qualquer
coisa na vida
não importa onde parou em que momento da
vida você cansou
o que importa é que sempre é preciso e
necessário recomeçar
recomeçar é tarde uma nova chance a si
mesmo é renovar a esperança na vida e o
mais importante é acreditar em você de
novo
acredito que tudo estava perdido
era o início de uma melhora onde quer
chegar a ir alto sonhar alto
queira o melhor do melhor se pensarmos
pequeno coisas pequenas teremos mais
desejamos fortemente melhor e
principalmente lutarmos pelo melhor
melhor vai ser em cima de nossas vidas
porque eu sou do tamanho daquilo que
vejo e não o tamanho da minha altura
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]